one of the most surprising senate races
this fall is in south carolina
where long time republican incumbent
lindsey graham
is trying to hold off democrat jamie
harrison
chief congressional correspondent mike
emanuel takes a look tonight
south carolina senator lindsey graham is
in the fight of his political life as
he's about to lead the confirmation
process
for judge amy coney barrett a recent
quinnipiac survey suggests it's a dead
heat with both graham
and democrat jamie harrison with 48
percent support
harrison has a money edge and is
receiving national
attention lindsey graham has gone all
washington d.c
he cares more about his political
relevance and power in washington
than doing the job that the people in
south carolina a debate scheduled for
tonight is now
off after the two sides could not reach
an agreement over covet testing
harrison demanded graham be tested while
graham declined saying he'll take
medical direction from a doctor
graham is trying to link harrison to
hillary clinton and house speaker nancy
pelosi
hoping that won't play well in south
carolina this is a big choice election
between me and mr harrison
capitalism versus socialism
conservative judges versus liberal
judges experts say graham leading the
barrett confirmation process
plays well with the republican base so
harrison
isn't directly attacking that he's
saying graham's not a man of his word
on the issue of confirming a supreme
court nominee in an election year
as for graham's very close relationship
with president trump
one south carolina analyst says there
could be coattails
but it's not going to be easy the
difference now is
he's got a very capable
and well-funded democratic opponent
the the harrison campaign has been
very professionally run typically the
big fight in south carolina is during
the republican primary
but not this cycle and a grand loss
would go a long way toward democrats
push to be in the majority
and be a huge prize for the progressive
left
brett mike emanuel thanks